[Musique]
vocaux c'est un magazine culturel
gratuit qui met en valeur le territoire
de la seine aval le nord des yvelines
dans différents domaines de la culture
que ce soit du patrimoine de la danse de
leurs plastiques de la musique
[Musique]
le magazine est né il ya cinq ans
maintenant on est au cinquième numéro
par un groupe d'amis en fait des
passionnés de patrimoine de culture on
s'est rendu compte que sur le territoire
finalement on n'avait pas beaucoup de
support de qualité pour valoriser les
lieux culturels donc on s'est dit qu'on
allait faire
par exemple de la réouverture du musée
emile zola à mais dans une rubrique
aussi sur un artiste donc un portfolio
aurélie richard on a une rubrique
musique une rubrique gastronomie une
rubrique aussi sur la graineterie à
houilles un lieu d'expression artistique
donc on retrouve voilà les mêmes
rubriques d'un numéro à l'autre
le domaine royal de marly à la fois le
parc et le musée en lui-même également
qu' qui est à découvrir
[Musique]